Німеччину заслужено вважають чемпіоном світу
із сортування та переробки сміття.
в 91-му запровадили так звану дуальну систему
поділу сміттєвих відходів.
Вона зобов'язує виробників пластикових упаковок,
а також фірми, які використовують їх
для своєї продукції, оплачувати їх утилізацію.
У Німеччині для кожного виду побутових відходів
призначений контейнер свого кольору.
Пластик викидається в жовтий.
Перед початком нового року міська служба з вивезення сміття
озсилає ось такі листи з розкладом на рік -
в який день, за яким видом сміття вони приїдуть.
У зазначений термін до шостої години тридцяти хвилин
відповідний контейнер повинен бути виставлений на вулиці.
Такі правила діють, перш за все, для приватних будинків.
Зазвичай пластикове сміття вивозять двічі на місяць.
Це - сортувальна станція компанії Ремондіс
в невеличкому містечку Тройсдорф на заході Німеччини.
Вона працює цілодобово шість днів на тиждень
з понеділка по суботу - в три зміни.
Щодня ми приймаємо від 200 до 300 тон сміття,
на рік виходить десь 50 тисяч тон
сміття, яке ми переробляємо.
На території станції відчувається легкий кислуватий запах.
Але він майже не заважає,
адже очікуєш значно гіршого.
Сортування виглядає приблизно так:
сміття вивантажують, спеціальні установки
розкривають пакети і висипають вміст.
На конвеєрах відбувається сам процес сортування:
спершу за розміром, потім - за матеріалом.
Упаковки з вмістом металу чи тетрапакові,
різні види пластику.
Співробітникам доводиться втручатися тільки якщо трапився збій -
найчастіше таке стається через те, що сміття неправильно викинули.
За словами Давида Шумахера, інколи їм доводилось
витягувати з пластикового сміття
автомобільні шини або кришки каналізаційного люка.
На жаль, маємо негативну тенденцію.
До нас звозять все більше залишкових відходів.
Якщо ставити оцінку, то в середньому
я б поставив людям за сортування сміття три з плюсом.
Думаю, що потрібно більше роз'яснювальної роботи.
Взяти хоча б пластиковий стаканчик для йогурту,
в якого кришка з алюмінієвої фольги.
Якщо ви відірвете фольгу,
ми краще утилізуємо стаканчик. Якщо фольгу не відривати,
то буде перероблено або пластиковий стаканчик,
або алюмінієву кришку.
Ось такий простий рух -
і ви вже долучилися до захисту довкілля.
До речі, згідно зі статистикою, Німеччина має
найкращий показник з утилізації упаковки в ЄС.
Половина цього сміття отримає друге життя,
а несортовану половину пластика - спалять.
Кожен житель Німеччини створює 37 кілограмів
пластикового сміття на рік.
З-поміж країн ЄС гірші показники тільки
в Ірландії, Люксембурзі та Естонії.